bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur votre
chaîne devenir l'ennemi politique la
scène si vous êtes dit cno en tissu ce
transfert dans notre dernière vidéo
on nous a expliqué une ordonnance et
l'utiliser quelques apporter un
gouvernement si ce n'est pas les
affaires je vous invite vivement à la
regarder pour bien comprendre ce qu'est
une ordonnance avant de regarder cette
vidéo car on va pas pouvoir tour est
expliqué ici alors juste pour rappel et
avant de commencer une ordonnance c'est
une norme prépare le gouvernement
dans un domaine qui est normalement du
domaine de la loi qui est donc du
domaine du parlement avant d'être
ratifié donc accepté par le parlement
elle se comporte comme un des traits
donc inférieur à une main et si elle est
acceptée par le parlement
sa valeur devient égale à celle du mans
et si les responsables syriens des
frères n'hésitez pas à aller voir notre
vidéo sur le sujet mais voilà après vous
avoir expliqué trivalle ordonnance on
s'est dit ça pourrait être intéressant
de vous aider à comprendre la différence
entre leur donnant à l'eau 49 francs
parce que beaucoup de jeunes considèrent
que c'est la même chose et il est vrai
qu'il est facile de se mélanger les
pinceaux
parce que oui que les deux procédures
vont raccourcir le débat parlementaire
qui va aussi forcément réduire le temps
consacré aux débats cumulée et pour les
deux procédures
on pourra dire que le gouvernement se
mêle des affaires ou par le monde
mais en fait mais pas exactement la même
idée derrière celle de procéder est
notre but ici est de vous impliquer
leurs différences pour rappel lors de la
procédure normale de vote des lois
le gouvernement peut proposer un projet
de loi qui sera lui discuté et débattu à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
les délais sont généralement assez long
pour que tous les parlementaires qui se
prendre connaissance du texte et
apporter leurs modifications
l'hôtel sera deux fois dans chaque
assemblée c'est ce qu'on appelle les
navettes parlementaires et modifier et
rediscuter à chaque fois pendant tout le
temps de la discussion
le texte n'a pas de valeur légale et une
fois le texte voté dans les mêmes termes
par les deux apprentis
le gouvernement doit mettre en place et
décrets d'application
le texte d'arriver et assez souvent
différent du teil de départ les députés
et les sénateurs n'ayant modifier à leur
image
maintenant passons à la procédure par 49
3 c'est à dire l'utilisation de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la constitution
le début c'est comme la procédure
normale
les parlementaires vont débattre mais si
le gouvernement estime que le débat est
trop le une qui pense que le texte ne
passera pas il stoppe le débat
parlementaire et impose son tête à un
challenge 9,3 à l'assemblée nationale
et même si c'est possible pour les
éviter de refuser ce passage en sorte en
votant ce qu'on appelle une motion de
censure en 49 3 n'a été censuré qu'une
seule fois sous la vème rajhi
donc dans presque tous les cas c'est le
gouvernement qui a le dernier mot et qui
en pose s'avère sans doute et c'est pour
ça que beaucoup considère le 49-3 comme
un passage en face
[Musique]
enfin pour finir en ce qui concerne les
ordonnances le gouvernement demande en
amont au parlement l'autorisation
d'écrire le texte avec un projet de loi
d'habilitation
c'est le parlement qui décide les délais
de mise en place et les domaines du
texte et en sang une fois le texte
rédigé en conseil délit c'est encore le
parlement qui décide de modifier le
texte ou non de l'accepter ou non comme
on l'avait dit dans la première vidéo
sur les ordonnances
le texte a une valeur réglementaire dès
sa publication au journal officiel
c'est à dire des chats signature par le
président de la république en france
avec des mini s'il n'est pas contraire à
une loi délimitant le contenu de
l'ordonnancé donc applicable dès sa
publication est généralement les délais
de présentation au parlement sont plus
courts que pour les lois normales
c'est une procédure qui est donc très
rapide parce que le texte n'a pas
attendre de passer par les navettes
parlementaires pour entrer en vigueur
donc voilà j'espère que vous aurez
compris que leur banc nancéen 49,3 sais
pas si ça c'est pareil dans la procédure
en ordonnant le parlement donne bel et
bien son accord au gouvernement pour
qu'il mette en place ce texte et peut
accepter ou refuser laser sur six
analysés
c'est donc le parlement c'est-à-dire
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat qui
reste maître du texte même si ce n'est
pas lui qui l'écrit il a le dernier mot
la réussite de l'ordonance dépendante de
la couleur du parlement
il faut quand même que je précise
quelque chose pour l'instant on n'a pas
parlé de la séparation des pouvoirs en
place qui font que théoriquement seul le
parlement peut décider des lic les
domaines de la loi sont en viendrez par
la constitution et les ordonnances
internet au gouvernement de passer
courts et précis ce qui de fatigue
évidents siècle équilibre des pouvoirs
en travers du gouvernement outre le
billet à bord c'est le problème de l'
ordonnance réside dans le fait que la
procédure est clean et pourra les ics et
pour faire passer une mesure rapidement
et qui dit rapidité des également
diminution il est bâti et du coup
l'ordonance ne laisse pas franchement le
temps aux différentes parties
intéressées de débattre et de proposer
des solutions alternatives aux solutions
proposées par le gouvernement
la procédure par ordonnance ne laisse
pas mal vu la possibilité aux citoyens
de s'intéresser à la question sur le
fond et de se mobiliser pour demander
autre chose et c'est ce manque de sens
plus que toute autre chose qui laisse
dans la population une impression de
passage enfants ou de non respect de la
démocratie et de l'opulent de sa carte
surtout si l'ordonnancé prise en plein
été pendant que le parlement est visé ce
personne n'a réellement la tête dans la
politique
avant ce film bien j'aimerais juste
révélé un dernier coup pour être sûr que
vous avez bien compris lors de
l'utilisation de la procédure anglaise
c'est le parlement qui décide de tout
c'est la façon habituelle de voter les
morts
la procession par ordonnance elle laisse
la possibilité au parlement de
s'exprimer sur le sujet et de modifier
ou refuser le tête mais elle délègue une
partie de son pouvoir un gouvernement
et elle entraîne un raccourcissement du
temps de débat et s'utiliser pour aller
vite pour finir le 43 c'est le coup de
force du gouvernement
il stoppe complètement le débat
parlementaire et impose la vision du
gouvernement
donc voilà cette vidéo est finie et
j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l'air
ou un nous mettre dans les commentaires
si li a d'autres sujets qui vous tente
bientôt on mettra en ligne une page vous
pourrez voter pour que nos revenus
youtube reviennent à des associations
alors n'hésitez pas à nous suivre sur
nos réseaux sociaux pour ne rien louper
bonne journée
[Musique]